hey guys how's it going it's Justine
back with another unboxing and today
this is something that I'm really
excited about I have had my eye on this
for quite a while and finally I was like
okay I'm buying it I need this in my
life mostly because the cameras that I
use are Sony other than the rx100 which
has a flip up screen these have a flip
up but like not flip to the side this is
my higher-end vlogging camera and then
the a7s2 which I'm using right here they
all have these screens that do not flip
out those one of the things that I
absolutely loved about Canon don't love
just being able to flip that screen to
the side really quickly see everything
that I need to see if for whatever
reason Sony is just so opposed to that
so hopefully in the next line of cameras
that they come out with they will take
us floggers into consideration my friend
Nick has been shooting a bunch of my
cooking videos for me recently he also
shot a lot of the iPhone 10 cinematic
shots that you guys probably saw in all
of my iPhone 10 videos so with that he
was using the Panasonic gh3 and this
camera has two SD card and you can
record for just however long you want to
unlike the Sony's which end up
overheating if you have them on longer
than an hour and they start recording
your shooting in 4k after about thirty
minutes I do feel like there's a lot of
things that Sony needs to address but
with all that being said I am by far the
biggest fan of Sony ever which is why
I'm unboxing this today which I haven't
even told you what I'm unboxing this is
that you focus Sony bundle this is by
small HD so what this is is a 5-inch
small HD screen it's a touchscreen and
this is the focus bundle so it comes
with this arm right here so you could
attach to the screen you could attach a
mic it also comes with a battery charger
looks like a micro HD camera I guess
I'll just find out why don't I just open
it and stop talking I've been waiting so
long I was like do I buy this do I not
buy this I don't really need needed
because matt has one so I've been
borrowing his smaller one but then he
needed it back so I said okay I guess
this is my time
it looks so good holy moly
Oh God why is this smell this smells
like the lawn and garden center of
Walmart so this does a micro-hdmi in
which is fine I just hope that it comes
with one of those cables because I don't
have one
oh it comes with a little glass face oh
this is good because I'd like to protect
my screen because I do not trust myself
okay nothing else in there what have we
got in here ooh all of our accessories
okay so it looks like it does come with
an HDMI cable which is very great oh wow
so I'm assuming that I can still use
some of the other batteries that I use I
have so many extra Canon batteries so I
usually do use those on the back of this
but this thing is as heavy as my camera
and it also states with this battery I
have use this camera here is our HDMI
cables looks like it comes with a
regular one a micro in a minute so this
looks like it has a HDMI adapter here's
the issue the microphone that I use is a
hot shoe mic so if I use this I'm now
gonna have to use a different microphone
and it's not really that big of a deal
because it gives us all these little
extras so I'm able to easily mount a
microphone over here if I would like to
there's a little hole that you have to
match up to on the side of this into
here so it'll go a little bit tighter
got myself a another microphone here so
this can just go right here on the side
it gives you some extra little adapters
so you can just attach these to the side
if you'd like
you guys are getting the first view I
don't even know what it looks like but
wow this looks so silly oh it's so crazy
that it's a touchscreen yeah guys this
is the future right here so the tripod
that I usually use I am a vlogger now
bring that battery it is so insane like
I can't believe it this will be so great
when I travel because I don't like to
bring a huge crazy setup like I have
right here but this will all kind of
condensed down very easily to be able to
pack it I did order this monitor through
bnh which I absolutely love not
sponsored I bought this just a full
disclosure I guess whatever deal B&H was
running it gave you a small HD case with
it too so I have like this nice little
Pelican case for it this is so heavy
well what am i doing but while this
screen looks so good I've got to get
that cover on there before this thing
gets destroyed so I've definitely gonna
mess around with this because I feel
like this isn't the ideal setup I don't
like where this microphone placement is
there's got to be something else that I
can do and maybe if I can even get like
a smaller microphone I could get
something hmm
well thank you guys for watching I hope
that you enjoyed this random unboxing of
my small HD screen this is the small HD
focus again if you guys are interested
I'll put a link in the description leave
me some comments below and let me know
if you guys think this is realistic
because it's not realistic am I crazy
it doesn't really even matter so you
know if you would carry this around in
public I'm not even sure if I can bring
myself to do that but we'll see I'll see
you guys in my next video
[Music]